horrific footage verified by chinese
state media shows the aircraft nose
diving to the ground in the remote
southern province of guangxi
the passenger plane operated by china
eastern airlines departed from the city
of kunming just after 1pm local time
it was headed to the city of guangzhou a
route which should have taken less than
two hours
when it suddenly lost altitude dropping
more than 6 000 meters in just two
minutes
videos circulating on social media show
a wildfire reportedly sparked by the
crash
the 132 people on board including 123
passengers and nine crew members are
feared dead
hundreds of emergency workers have been
dispatched to the site president xi
jinping has called for an immediate
investigation
analysts say the boeing model 737-800
aircraft has a good safety record the
737 800 has been uh workhorse and i
believe that
china eastern have
over 600 jet aircraft and
i think they've got um somewhere along
the lines of
137.37 so
it's a very reliable aircraft and
it's uh it's quite a amazing story that
an aircraft can crash on a two-hour
flight
the boeing 737 800 is a predecessor of
the 737 max a model that has been banned
from commercial use in china after two
crashes within months that killed 346
people in indonesia and ethiopia
the crash is china's worst aviation
disaster in years its safety record has
been among the best in the world for a
decade
though experts have questioned the
reporting of safety lapses china eastern
airlines says it's mourning the loss of
those on board and has grounded all of
its boeing 737-800 aircraft until
further notice
katrina you al jazeera beijing